[Music]
a little bit of work man that don't
scare us i get up i go hard like i'm
george harris make plays break lanes
push away break
[Music]
welcome to another episode of fight
night flashbacks with my right-hand man
here you know him from the sing from
king to sting the wing and the sing whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
i'm old school man it's eric griffin
and uh on today's episode i am going to
take you through the legendary career of
amanda nunes she is by most regards the
best female fighter of all time wow and
i'm gonna show you why well you know
what the other night we just thought we
were watching uh on the fight companion
uh you know i've never watched a a full
female fighting you know and i've i've
said to you before on other podcasts
where i'll like i'm really not into this
but you know
because of doing this and and talking to
you and talking to fans now i i have a
whole new appreciation for this but it's
still tough though when i see the women
and that fight was that was the most
brutal fight i've ever seen that was a
tough one for you to watch your first
female yeah that was the most brutal
fight i've ever seen and now i have a
little bit more appreciation a sense of
like the chess match that goes on in
these fights so it was very fascinating
but still very brutal but you'll see too
why uh amanda nunes you know because the
girl that you saw her fight that was a
rematch against juliana pena
and julian penny even though she won the
first fight you know she surprises one
of the i think third or fourth biggest
upset uh
according to the odds makers in ufc
history but even coming into the fight
that we watched on the the last one uh
on the cowbest fight campaign amanda
nunez was still the favorite you know so
and i see why you're gonna see why you
but
i saw why in that fight but that one you
definitely saw yeah but but you're gonna
see why like leading up to that why she
is the baddest on the planet and why was
such an upset when paying your bills
correct big big deal got it but um we're
going to kick this off this is the
legendary ufc 200. now you're going to
notice that
the octagon is pp yellow and they decide
to do a special like thing for ufc 200
and uh it didn't
it
ufc 100 was
insane i was there ufc 200 so every 100
that tried to blow it out right this one
was tough the ufc there was a they're
supposed to be dc and jon jones on there
jon jones had some issues so then dc end
up financing silva so then they're the
main event the whole thing was kind of a
[ __ ] show including starting with this
mat but uh why what's wrong with the
yellow map it's just not what they do
and they want to make it special it was
just on tv you'll see it just doesn't
look cool
it was too much but um so she's fighting
a girl here named misha tate now misha
tate top
i don't know top four or five female
fighters of all time she's she's very
famous she retired and now she's back in
ufc she went to go work for one
championship her nickname is cupcake um
she was a champion in strikeforce she
you know her and rhonda have a history
together but um
you know she's she's definitely one of
the most popular uh fighters to ever
come out of the ufc uh sure as hell for
female and then you know she checks all
the boxes she's skilled and then she's
also really pretty okay and what's her
uh what's her special grappling
grappling and so is that so going into
this fight is that what she was trying
to do yep
hit it
yeah you'll see i mean yeah all this
damn advertisement on the mat is just as
much
what they did with the ufc back then the
reebok deal they went hey let's take all
the money from the fighters and just put
it on the mat yeah and that's what they
did
but yeah i mean misha state she's not a
bachelor but her specialty is jiu jitsu
like her jiu-jitsu is pretty filled
looks like she's got a good punch
yeah she is you know and she's also
especially now i'd say she's a a bigger
name than a man nunes at this point
because um uh mistake right now she's
currently the champ right so she's a
champ right now it's ufc 200 and this
started the freaking
destruction path of amanda nunez what's
she
this is her first big fight yeah that's
how she got the belt oh okay yeah so
this this other woman was the champ
already yep enemy state was a big deal
ooh big big deal
that seems to happen a lot in uh ufc for
with women
meaning what do you mean like there's
somebody who's a big deal then she just
gets demolished sometimes yeah yeah
sometimes i mean because i haven't heard
of her yeah like just casual
it's a good take down yeah that's what
she's trying to do right yeah and she uh
trains out of spokane washington oh wow
yeah
okay she had to spoken about oh she's
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
my god man
she probably got in a lot of trouble
when she was a kid
in the principal's office all the time
in brazil yeah or is it
yesterday in brazil
i imagine you get a call your daughter
beat up like two or three people you
just come home she didn't just start
fighting you know
my son would come home with like a gold
crown made out of paper like oh i got
classmate of the day and she comes home
like i got classmate dave what'd you do
beat some girls down yeah
i bet she was beating up boys when she
was a kid oh oh oh that's almost an
illegal shot because you're not allowed
to knee a down opponent there oh yeah so
that was
iffy but they're letting it roll but you
can tell me she's slowing down starting
to get lit up on the side slowing down i
think that i i've been watching since
that one good punch she hasn't been the
same but you'll see what if when amanda
nunes lands you're gonna see the four
fights you watch when she lands it she
has to be the hardest hitting female
fighter of all time swede lands these
girls aren't the same oh yeah this is it
no this girl hasn't been the same
it's over the one hearts yeah look at
him yeah look at she's okay she's like
so hard but she's already
she look at this oh the fear oh man i
totally get this that's the thing with a
man in this she hit you oh yeah yeah
she's dying oh my god yourself stop it
but you'll see it's a common theme with
all these fights she hits it's
they're never the same like it's not
snowflake that's not stuff like you know
what i'm saying she's just whooping
their ass
yeah now amanda is also she at this
current time she's trying to have att
which is one of the biggest uh training
camps in in the world
they have phenomenal fighters out of
there and they're the best of all time i
mean to me they should have stopped this
fight already correct this this other
chick has is done she stopped fighting
like
45 seconds ago she was she's kind of lit
up yeah so you know the fight we watch
with july opinion
i said no i could have finished that i
just wanted to show
that i was better in every single facet
and wanted to prove it
man
that's just god damn damn that's tough
because that actually also takes away
from yeah she's that yeah yeah tap out i
mean
that'll you know what i don't oh man
that that's something else because
hearing that because
we
everyone was saying man pena really
survived that like how what respect you
got for that and for her to say that it
takes that all the way up she was like
they're getting compliments yeah yeah
yeah take that away yeah man so now that
i
just told you guys that i allowed her to
go on yeah how do you feel now how do
you like it now she almost shouldn't
have done that
but that's so she becomes champion here
she's out of att becomes champion and
then just goes on this reign and then
i would say before this if you ask
anybody even with this fight hey she's
gonna be the greatest female fighter of
all time you're like get out of here bro
but then she goes on this freaking
destruction well listen man if she just
demolished that girl that girl is good
listen i'm just i'm looking at her for
the first time this is when it was done
that's what you're like yeah she changed
that look at her that she was fighting
with fear after that look at this just
her whole demeanor was like okay
okay stop hitting me
okay you won
class don't be come on don't be a [ __ ]
stop it but what's this about man nunez
you're gonna see a change of guard how
you were saying like these big names and
they get beat the [ __ ] up yeah you're
gonna see with amanda nuna she's the one
that does that because right misha tate
old school kind of changing the guard
then she fights ronda rousey again old
school changing the guard holly holm old
school changes so she's beating these
big so she now at what point did she
beat ronda rousey as is it after holly
holmes beat her yeah so that fights is
that what's next mike so this the one
against ronda rousey it's interesting
because uh don't play it yet might be
this one's interesting because so you
know rhonda loses to holly holm which
shocks the world right one of the
biggest upsets of all time were you
shocked
i was very shocked i was very close to
ron at the time i was very very shocked
okay i'm sorry
um
i think anybody that was around her knew
that her striking was a liability and
that holly holm uh had a lot of
a lot more experience and could do that
to her but i don't think anybody was
even like yeah she's gonna get straight
up
ko'd with a head kick like that okay as
a novice or just just somebody that just
knows nothing about this
when i saw them in the rings next to
each other i said
oh that big girl is going to beat that
little girl up yeah that's fair that's
just that's fair that's just it's just
looking at it but you know that and i
think and i think anybody that would
like that wasn't really into it you kind
of just heard this person's name it was
like ronda rousey he's like mike tyson
that's how they like they sold and
that's and that's what [ __ ] her
because a lot of people in the ufc
community dana white a lot of big names
commentators running she's like mike
tyson and it's like i mean you're really
no she's not no no what but then she
started listening to that and then when
your bread and butter's submission your
is your arm by your submission game but
you're being told you're mike tyson like
i'm gonna knock girls out it's like what
and then eventually you can run in
somebody where you're striking is
nowhere near their level like holly holm
here's what's interesting about holly
holm before we watch this ronda rousey
men in this fight holly holm
uh
previously before the ufc was a world uh
multiple time world champion kickboxer
when she got to the ufc she was with
greg jackson's camp and you'll see she's
fighting these girls
but she could take them out earlier
but the entire how badass is this her
entire career when she got in the ufc
was to beat ronda rousey
every fight she would game plan like it
was ronda rousey so she'd work on
something so when she finally got to
ronda it would help her beat ronda well
sure did so this is this is rhonda verse
uh so this is
our for her she already had her first
loss first last long layoff and here's
the red flags you know
this ended her career oh yeah yeah so
the ufc you know they
rhonda was their cash cow with the face
the ufc you know basically the hoist
gracie of uh female fighting you know
she won the biggest stars ever do it
kudos to her
she was always really good with the
media and stuff like that the first red
flag for everybody should have been is
dan went rona's not going to do any
press leading up to the fight like
wait what that's never happened ever in
the history of fighting ever yeah she
goes she's not going to do any press
like well that's weird what's going on
here it does feel weird let you know
like mentally she wasn't she wasn't
there let's take a little break from
chatting with my boy eric griffin just
filling him in educating him on amanda
noon as the greatest female fighter of
all time
and she's putting a lot of people to
sleep and hopefully they're getting good
sleep with these knockouts because i get
great sleep with helix mattresses that's
right
every bed in my household is helix
mattresses i can't grow my in-laws my
family wants to stay with me all the
time like oh it's because i'm a nice guy
nope because they love helix mattresses
helix mattress listen they're built for
you not your average joe mattress not a
mattress built for everybody you take a
quiz it takes two minutes to complete
then they match you with your thick body
with the perfect mattress built just for
you not for every joe shmoe built for
you if you like mattresses that are
really soft firm you sleep on your side
your back guy you sleep really hot
really cold whatever helix got gotcha
covered man your unique taste will be
covered with helix mattresses you'll
need to take my word for it helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress of 2019 2020 by gq and wired
magazine just go to helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz they'll
match you with a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life the they have a 10-year
warranty you can try out 100 nights
risk-free they even pick it up if you
don't love it but you're well again
that's helix all right helix is offering
you guys up to 200 buckaroos off all
mattress orders and free pillows for the
listeners and viewers of this show fight
night flashback with eric griffin and
myself and this one's feature amanda
nunez all you got to do is go to
helixsleep.com that's helix
h-e-l-i-x-sleep.com
shob for 200 buckaroos off hit it
and it there couldn't be a worse fight
this is i mean you're throwing chum in
the water to a goddamn brazilian female
great white shark yeah cause look at
amanda nunes you know what i'm saying
okay doesn't touch gloves you know well
okay
yeah this one's bad dude you know she
just and she just hits like a mac truck
but then
you know your coaches are telling you
mike tyson you're you know look at her
oh he's just getting lit up dude
and the shame about this is you know
ronda was a pioneer oh my god ronald was
a pioneer of the sport and like such a
legend and it's just like
for this be your last outing it's just
not i don't think she went down like
this yeah well i mean again it's not
even a fight bro again i was about to
say after that first punch it's already
done yeah she hit her
her whole demeanor is like that okay
that's it i'm out get me out of here
but you know the game evolves fast
remember hoist grace was able to do it
for a while that's it
i mean
amanda nunes didn't get that's the
easiest payday she's ever had
and this is it for her she's like yeah
run is that now there's talk that ron is
going to fight um
um gina carano they talked about they're
both older you know it's the one fight
that i think gina would come out first
one fight that
um ronda would come out for but at this
point
why why ron is a mom what are we doing
you know but i guess you could do it so
she was she had a chip on look at she
still got a chip on her shoulder no one
gave her even then no one gave her a
chance even after watching the hollywood
home fight people you know
kind of just was like ah we'll see but
you know
for rhonda yeah it's going to be coming
i don't know hey next time shaking my
hand yeah
this ain't going to talk about
holy [ __ ] oh that's it that's it oh my
god oh my gosh that wow she got like
four
she got like four look at her face she's
just like oh this is you could boom
something i notice about this is there's
moments in these fights that all these
fights i've watched now with you
there are moments in these fights where
the fight's done
the other person is like i am
overmatched i'm talking about the men's
and the women's oh yeah did they just go
wow
i just got i don't know if i'm gonna be
get be able to get out of this you know
i think they're waiting for the fight to
end as opposed to trying to win anymore
you know what
i feel you the problem is is and it's
it's tough as a referee you know
stopping that
and he did the right to uh oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh
he was like oh
man oh my god
oh man
yeah yeah you got to stop this yeah
she's out yeah it's such a shame man oh
right there she looks like look at the
coach like how could they stop that you
know that's the problem
she looked like elliot page right there
for a second
time out
now yeah okay
confused
so this next one i think uh you know all
the wins are big leading up to it but
this one to me solidified her being the
greatest female champion of all time or
basically the best female fighter of all
time so this is actually at a
featherweight this is at 145. so you
think about there's not a lot anything
about it 145 pound girl professional
fighter there's not a lot of fighters at
that weight but the one who is probably
a lot of girls at that way but they're
just not professional fighters correct
especially now yeah body positive
anyways
but uh
this this so the but the one thing at
145 is this brazilian demon named chris
cyborg who got in strikeforce bellator
she came with the ufc finally wait what
strike force again has to europe no
strike force used to be a big time uh
american organization and the ufc bought
them and they took all the talented
roster and just put them in oh god you
got yourself they folded the business
and brought all their talent to the ufc
it's like there's a lot of times like
how they used to be an aba in the nba
then they combined correct so and from
strikeforce you had you so ronda came
out there robbie lawler dc
um misha tate uh uh woodley um mazel
doll was there
a lot a lot of people kimbo slice and it
didn't make any sense for the for the
for the sport to have a lot of different
leagues is that nobody i mean the knock
on the ufc is the monopoly right so you
can't have any other competition but
yeah but so is the nba so the nfl yeah i
agree i'm i'm with him i'm not mad i
mean that's what you want to have all
the best talent be in the same place the
uc also did it with pride which pride
was like
for the real fight heads the gay
fighters is it
i didn't think of that dude yeah pride
was really big come here [ __ ]
[Music]
bring a [ __ ] you better not have monkey
pops
but pride was like a big organization in
asia like the biggest and some of the
most historic fighters came out there
ufc bought them and folded them and you
know so it's business i get it conquered
but i mean i i think that for a sports
organization
i think that they're i mean i think that
they should find a way where like i
guess there's camps within the
organization like franchises but they're
all apart under the ufc umbrella so when
you get a champ it's like the you know
the people's champ right you know that's
the problem with boxing yeah
yeah all that [ __ ] like wait what
i think the problem with all this
fighting is in my opinion that there
should be a
there should be a season and you know
when it's coming we should all know the
leaderboards we should all know who's
who should be facing who uh there's a
the pfl does that where they have
seasons and tournaments but with ufc and
that's just year round i'm not mad at it
because it's all about individuals yeah
yeah i get i get i get it's a whole
different thing so this fight is to me
the most important fight in her career
because this chris cyborg you'll see her
it's the first time you're going to see
where amanda nunes just looks like a
normal person cyborg is first of all
jacked hits harder than i do and she is
legendary legend let me i have a
question and a very nice person do you
think that amanda nunez if she would
have fought ronda rousey before ronda
rousey fought holly holmes would she a
beater oh good question
um
that's a good question with rhonda you
know her her um
lack of experience at a high level of
striking was going to catch up to her i
think whether it was holly or it was
amanda
she was just it was just a matter of
time before she met that crossroads and
it was just
holly was the was the one
unfortunately let's take a little break
from chatting with my boy eric griffin
about amanda nunes i'm just trying to
help him out educating some of the
baddest fighters on the planet that's
all this is that's all this is man and
you're probably like man brendan knows
his amanda nunes facts yeah but listen i
have a little help a little help from
kratom the kratom is what i use for
every podcast stand up you name it your
boys on kratom but you can't trust all
kratom's out there there's only a few
brands you can trust it's the wild west
like cbd back in the day all right
kratom helps you energize your mind it
relaxes your body it just helps you feel
good you'll feel so you feel like elon
musk that's why i take it but i'm not
i'm the forest gump of elon musk all
right superspeciosa has only one
ingredient that's pure kratom leaf all
right all that's all it is you look at
the ingredients pure kratom leaf that's
what you want out of your kratom all
right for beginners i recommend capsules
because they're easy to use that's what
i take i also recommend the green strain
that's the most popular for a reason you
get 100 satisfaction guaranteed or your
money back all right it's fantastic try
creating right now if you always want to
try it try it out get 20 off and go to
get super leaf dot com slash shob
s-e-h-a-b and get 20 off with the promo
code shob s-e-h-a-b that's get super
leaf dot com slash shob and use the
promo code shop for 20 off get you some
kratom now let's get back to the program
so he hit it mike this this fight is not
nuts this is my favorite female fighter
look at her oh jesus christ get some
eric
i can't jack bro she wish black belt in
jiu jitsu
notoriously known as
the legit mike tyson female fighting
like knocks [ __ ] cold
cold
that back tattoo son yeah but no no no
so she's winging them right now watch
amanda nuna she's more precise she's
shooting down the center of the pipe and
her speed
and also look at amanda's uh
mental state like most people
look oh bro that was the one bro that
was the one
nobody hits cyborg like this nobody the
the the defending
oh jesus nobody touches cyborg like this
boom
what oof what
and and she before this was considered
the grace of all time boom that's it
flat out bro and it's a speed it's a
speed advantage so then uh manones
became not only uh the bantamweight
champ but also the featherweight champ
so the 135 and 145 champ
yeah mcdaniel i can't get up there she's
but also first trying to tell him you're
gonna be paying me more money now
but also but also for dana you know
cyborg was always she never got along
with dana white so her coming to the ufc
was like dana was like all right you
want to talk all this [ __ ] let's see
what you got so i would be willing to
bet dana insider was like yes
that's what you get you know
and then she she left you'll see you
know shortly after this yeah there's
also nobody no female fighters at 145
pounds there's just no one for her to
fight
but for for her to take cyborg out like
that to me most important part of her
career because to me it was like it was
either her or amanda all right well they
fought
now granted this isn't cyborg in an
ultimate prime but it's a pretty [ __ ]
good cyborg
but the speed of a man nunes and the
technique and the not being loopy and
just being her to the punch and knocking
her out like that nuts
you're about to say the emotion she's
feeling right there so i have a question
i want to know
like so holly had beaten ronda rousey
and she's beaten ronda rousey but what's
the context of this fight how many
fights is this in till now or she's
fighting holly's yeah why is this a huge
fight yes oh holly would have fought ron
in 2015 this ufc 239 so this is 2017. so
this is two years later and to be honest
like holly beats ronda and that is kind
of the pinnacle of her career and then
she
she loses three in a row so monsters are
like chef chenko
duranomi like tough fights same weight
classes different no she was losing
those at 35 so then holly goes you know
what i'm gonna go to 45 and see i can
compete there and amanda nunes goes will
i'll be your huckleberry right and so
this is two years later so she ended
another career this one
yeah man
yeah man all right hit it mike yeah
she's just destroying girls
but yeah when you think about you know
holly pinnacle career then for the ufc
it must be tough because she knocks
round out like that and then go on a
three fight losing skit
god damn it you beat our champ to me it
says more about ronda rousey than it
says about
holly holm there you go
yeah but listen it's all about
the styles make fights and
holly has the perfect style to do what
she did against rhonda
yeah that's at 145. so holly at 145 is
writing two there's only three girls
though you know right right right right
there's about four girls in the world
you like two yeah it's like all right
if you're four and your records three
and 19 or some [ __ ] yeah
but then again for for amanda again this
is a to me this is another
you know feather in her cap to point
that she's the greatest female fighter
of all time because think how good holly
is at stand-up you know she's a
world-class kickboxer right right much
of america's cool you kickboxer that's
cool
and i think too you look at a man who
knows confidence if you saw him when she
lost that first fight to
pena she just didn't want to be there
man and i think
success um you know having money she's
talking about married kids they had a
kid yeah she's like
and then you know raquel pence i'm sorry
um
uh
um pena is just this you know hungry
starving
fighter you know ultimate fighter but
anybody in this sport could get caught
two ways with a good punch or uh in a
submission hold right easily there's two
there's too many ways to lose at this
level especially in the ufc so if you
talk to any like professor and gambler
like someone who's like a degenerate
professional gambler they don't bet on
ufc there's too many ways to lose yeah
yeah yeah basketball like
college football pro football come on
bro i mean you know what i'm saying like
if a team turns it on they're usually
generally on but yes there's two you
don't know the mental state of the
the fighter well she kicked her in the
head man
what a kick that was a that was a decent
kick
you know holly's known for her footwork
so she's she's hard to track down man
you know yeah i could see that but for
holly too you know
she's newer to mma even though she
kicked rhonda in the freaking head oh my
god when she comes
yeah yeah she's a super technical
kickboxer but you know for holly holm
also you know lots of chef chanko who
technically is a better uh striker you
know uh
uh randomies also phenomenal striker so
but they're emma they they've been doing
mma longer so for holly was just a lack
of experience inside i was gonna say i
mean i think that
the common denominator here is like you
know you have
uh
you know ronda rousey in this and it
just seems as if she really wasn't
you know
what we wanted her to be and like if you
take her out of this scenario and it was
just the people that were left
uh what kind of what kind of like
landscape would have been
and this is this is what i think makes
rondo so special is you know dana before
rhonda goes we're never going to have
women in the ufc it's never going to
happen then veronda who's in strikeforce
pulling off all these crazy arm bars
he sees her he's like well there might
be something there so if rhonda wasn't
the you know must-see tv female fighter
that dana saul
there's no amanda known as
you guys they don't have like rhonda you
know
like stand-up wise and skill-wise yeah
they're talented
you know brian a pretty girl
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah i got you guys
so she had she was the entertainment
portion she checked all boxes sports
basketball this is sports entertainment
she was the hoist gracie of female
fighting like
it's easy to look in hindsight and i'm
like well she lost her last two it's
like no i don't mean that i just meant i
just i didn't i just meant that it
seemed as if she wasn't it wasn't uh the
fighter that they thought she was or
maybe she wasn't she just got outdone
uh which one is it yeah i think it's a
combination of both i think she was that
special and
but also you gotta realize female
fighting is even newer than male
fighting so right right it's advancing
so fast and you know she had a camp
around her going oh you're the best
striker ever when she should have been
grappling all in wrestling her entire
camp [ __ ] forgot you she's had such an
advantage grappling but then she got oh
my god she had kicked that kick
that's what's nuts bro
oh you had kicked rhonda say less
i'm the best female fighter of all time
at 145.
wow
yeah
please make a t-shirt whatever that was
that's the toes
wow i was just about to say that she won
the fight on a head kick how nuts is
that yeah and that just shows you how
you know you know
she's the best not only because she
beats these girls but the way she does
yeah because she's she seems to want to
beat people at their own game
yeah i'm sorry that i had to beat you at
your own game crazy right yeah look at
that oh man i you know one thing that's
hard for me to watch when i watch these
things too is like
yeah you really like you really
legitimately see the disappointment oh
bro like that's like that's like some
real like man how does that must how
does that feel you've lost a few fights
yeah i mean i've won some i've won i've
lost some but it's like how does it feel
because you prepared you and then you
just watched it but you know it's like
it's like uh
like the the peaks are the highest ever
and the valleys are the lowest there's
no middle ground so it would be this is
this why fighting sucks so for holly
right for you as a comic it would be
like you your bomb at carnegie hall or
something no let's say you finally get
mad square garden right and you eat dick
and then for everyone sees it like the
entire yeah yeah yeah yeah all comedy
fancy it yeah and then uh some like you
some hate you already so they're like
yeah and then uh you can't perform again
for another six to eight months oh you
have to just
sit in that filth yeah of being a loser
for six to eight years it's not like you
can go do a quick fight at the comedy
store no it's not like fight rink you
know what yeah exactly
let me redeem myself
[ __ ] y'all that's the crowd no no
nuts and the thing about ufc that i find
fascinating too is that like so she
kicked her and the girl was out you know
and then it was like she went in that
you have to stop the fight at that point
right the rest and it's funny because
even holly at the on the ground was like
okay okay [ __ ] okay
stealing that you know what i mean she's
like all right you got me i'm done you
won the fight move but it's just the way
they're trained like and it's it's more
on the ref like the ref they just gotta
be quicker too but it's tough man oh
that raffle is quick he he practically
you can see how that rap could have beat
him
what is with chris hanson
you know the pedophile gets tackled in
the in the grass catch a predator that's
how herb dean tackles the fighters yeah
he like he he he put a little extra on
pushing her out i don't know if i'm like
hey
that's it man amanda nunez you watched
her at her best you know beat up julian
so she just has how many losses one loss
no she has a few losses but you know
that julian opinion before that julian
penny when she had a loss in a hot
second now here's what's interesting we
can dive into another episode but
there's now there's some hype because
there's a girl who's at a lower weight
class named uh
valentina shevchenko who
technically is a better
technical fighter she's more decorated
um and they've they've fought twice
already and a man has beat her twice
right one was split decision that some
people thought chef changer won but now
shivchenko's been now she's like so
they're going to fight a third time that
but what do you do that what do you do
with that because she fights out 25 so
you do it at 30 do you remember right
they both have to one comes up one comes
down so i think that's the fairest thing
i think you had a catch weight at 130
and make it a bmf title and then have it
you know do that but so that's her and
she is a [ __ ] firecracker bro she is
fantastic jesus is that meatball
no comment dude yeah she's a savage
though but they they can't do that you
know 35 they can't do it at 25 so do a
catchweight 30 see who's the best of all
time the only issue there is amanda's
beat her twice yeah it's like tough it's
tough i'll tell you what i can do is a
rematch uh trilogy fight with uh julian
pena they have to fight another one no
because because it was they're ten eight
rounds so
through the ufc you're like it's kind of
like matt sarah gsb which is the biggest
upset of all time just be you know pound
pound won the grace of all time fights
matt sarah from the ultimate fighter
short little you know meatball italian
dude he knocks gsb out
they rematch gsp beats the [ __ ] out of
them which should have probably happened
in the first case the uc goes we're
good we don't need a third like we saw
what happened i'm assuming they do have
julian pena do your opinion will be your
champ because amanda nunez only has one
or two fights well it would be up to you
to me it should be i think all
everyone in fighting
should take a page out of jake paul's
book meaning
meaning
be a personality
it's tough though if that's not in your
i know but
that you got to make that part of your
thing it's like you sound like a comic
or old school comic like myself being
like ah tick-tock and and uh instagram
and all that now you don't need that
what do you need that for you know what
i mean without a podcast a little bit
but it's a little bit
a little bit like mitzi being like once
you put on a suit and change your name
like i don't want to do that gimmick
that's not me like can't i am aren't i
good enough to sell tickets as with my
skill set yeah no no
[Laughter]
put a suit on yeah no man get the puppet
out i understand i'm living that i'm
living that reality so it's like i
totally get why i'm i think that people
should i mean the guy
you know it's like this is we have to
remember that this is sports
entertainment it there is a specialty
that's not the nfl nba where they don't
give a [ __ ] you're going to get paid no
they do but i don't know but that's
still they do get but it is sports
entertainment there too like lebron
james has became a billionaire and he
became my first personality though dude
i think very much so again it became
about about his uh hit all his off the
court stuff his persona and all that you
know michael jordan did the same thing
they're also the greatest ever dude i
know i know but what i'm saying they
said
i know but it's like there are people
who are really great like tim duncan
who was
he's greatest power forward ever agree
mr fundamentals but he wasn't off the
court being like gatorade and all that
kind of stuff
he just what he just wanted to play but
what i'm saying is to get to the next
level he also
retired with 400 million in the bank so
that's
those sports are different because in
the ufc to actually make [ __ ] you money
you to your point you have to have some
the fans have to like right then but
what i'm saying is which that's then it
would it would call for a third fight
there you go that's what she's doing
because these people are like in the
public eye and they're on their
instagram they're on their thing i'm
just saying like get out there fighters
but i also think from your perspective
and if i'm wrong be like shut the [ __ ]
up
i also think you're a little bit like
don't taste right you're a little bit
like tim duncan we're yeah i know you're
mr fundamentals i know but hold up let
me finish the compliment phenomenal
comic monster like when you do shop and
friends i mean you crush harder than any
of us
we have
jeff died monsters daf again uh you name
it uh louis ck's been on there you
crashed hard on all of us
but then you're not like mr social media
you're not mr merch you're not miss you
know you're trying to think that's what
i'm that's what i've recently in the
last year been like really trying to
focus on that because it's like that is
part of the business that is needed and
that's what i'm saying about like for
everyone in the industries of
entertainment whatever it is
comedy is entertainment sports
entertainment yes entertainment
entertainment
there has to be a level of like you have
to get in on these things to reach the
people
agree do you take offense i called you
the tim duncan no no no no no no no no
no because i get it it's like you know
you know what i mean it's like because
you're a monster
like you're asking the nba player i'm
like tim duncan [ __ ] monster yes the
kids are like what yeah they don't know
yeah oh all right well tim duncan i'm
sorry good job
hopefully this show helps you you're
like you like zion we have to put a
weight claws on your contract
sorry man
see you next time see you guys thanks
tuning in